hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor it's sunday
it's 7 00 p.m you know what that means
that means that i'm going to be
answering your property investment
questions so
do me a favor help me out comment below
with your property investment questions
any question that you have it's not too
stupid
it's not too complex just comment below
and then i'm gonna do my very best to
answer your questions
also do me a massive favor and smash the
like button
also subscribe below turn the
notification bell on because how
disappointing would it be
if i answer your question next week and
then you don't even know because you
didn't get notified of me doing a new
video so subscribe
turn the bell on and let's get started
so
last week we had a whole bunch of
questions about property some real good
questions so one guy called jack said
i'm looking to get into property before
i do my first deal should i create a
limited company or do it under my
personal name
so jack what i'll say is there
are tax advantages to buying through a
limited company
namely section 24 doesn't apply so you
can claim your mortgages
mortgage payments is tax-deductible also
you can pay yourself as you grow your
portfolio
you can pay yourself a salary and then
uh like a small silo of eleven thousand
pound which is tax-free
and then the majority then the rest up
to about forty thousand pounds
you're going to take out as a dividend
where you're only going to pay seven and
a half percent
so listen i'm not a tax uh advisor so
check with an accountant
but i would say it's much more tax
efficient to buy it through a limited
company
does that mean that you need to go
tomorrow and set up a limited company
no it doesn't do you know what you need
to do tomorrow jack you need to go and
find a deal
because if you're gonna find a deal and
you put an offer on and the offer is
accepted
you can then put set up a limited
company it takes like
24 hours to set up a limited company so
don't worry about tax
don't worry about your business cards
don't worry about your company name
worry about finding property deals
paul mcandrew me and my wife are 21
looking to get on the property ladder as
soon as possible we've got 5 000 pounds
saved at the moment what would you
recommend to get on the ladder fast
paul what i'd say is i wouldn't worry
about getting on the ladder fast
because it's not about being on the
property ladder
that means you've achieved anything
great what what's what's great is when
you can achieve an income coming in a
passive income
and for sure property is a great way to
achieve a passive income
but i wouldn't be thinking i need to i
need to get on the ladder
i need to get on the ladder lots of
people are on the ladder and they're in
the rat race
and they get a mortgage and then they
just have to pay the mortgage it's more
expensive
so make sure that when you do buy a
property make sure that it's an
investment
make sure that it's putting money in
your pocket every single month um
if you've got five thousand pound that's
great good for you that's a good start
i would work on trying to think how you
can create more cash flow and how you
can do that now
you don't necessarily need to be on the
ladder to start making cash flow you
know you could do rent to rents you
could do deal sourcing
um there's lots of there's lots of
things you could do but
you know i i'm glad to see that you're
excited to get to get in
property but what i wouldn't do is go
and get help to buy scheme
move into a new build house just to be
like yes
this is our home and we own it because
it's not about who owns their home it's
about who's got the most wealth and
who's got the most monthly cash flow
coming in
so that you can have a life of freedom
okay hope that helps
tiego silva i agree with you or comes
with wolverhampton cc i don't know what
that means
i did this i did the same this year
emailed birmingham cc maybe city council
and they asked me to prove i was
refurbishing the property according with
hmo policies even i was not able to meet
the deadline
i i got quotes from vendors just to
cover us covert came in and then we got
the property on time
sadly hmm august did not go ahead i
think we we had to give up
i think we had to give up
you don't need to give up okay it's so
it sounds to me i i think i understand
what you're saying a little bit um tiago
and it sounds like you've had a little
bit of
a little bit of pain a little bit of a
headache with the councils and
hate getting a hmm mortgage and you know
can i just say number one that is
completely normal you are
not alone just because it was hard and
you had a headache
doesn't mean that you should quit that
is standard in property
second thing is get around good people
why
learn from your own mistakes when you
can get around people that are six
months ahead and you can learn from
their mistakes
so you know get back on the horse get
around good people
i hope to see you at the property
investors crash course um
you know where there's going to be
hundreds of property investors
in the room that are all supporting one
another getting the knowledge
but don't give up because that is what
happens in this game
discipline your disappointment as much
as celebrating your success
louise louis smith can you please go
through
every way to buy a property how to
refinance
and how to buy development land thanks
wow
every way okay you want to know
basically what you just said is tell me
everything there is to know about
property ever
in one comment on a q a sunday so um
i'll do my best i mean everybody
look there's so many ways to buy
property how do we finance and how do
you want to talk about development um
there's there's three
there's lots of different ways but
there's three figures you need to look
at you just look at how much you're
buying the house for
purchase price don't get mixed up
between the market value and the asking
price
the two very different things so you
want to buy the price the properties
cheapest
possible using negotiation ninja
techniques that i teach
um you then want to do the property up
find a property with a problem
that you can fix and you want to fix
that problem every time you spend a
pound fixing it you need to be adding
three pounds made to the house
um and then and then and then know what
the end value is going to be
speak to valuers speak to independent
estate agents do your comparables
um but you can push the value up so many
ways you can turn a property into a hmo
you can
um you can you can fix make it
mortgageable when it was unmortgageable
you can buy a property for cash flow and
you can rent it out room by room or you
can rent it out of service to
accommodation on a short stay lecture
you haven't got to deal with tenants and
you've got high cash flow
and there's tax advantages geez if you
haven't got any money
you can rent a property off somebody who
doesn't know what they're doing very
well amateur landlord or someone that
doesn't know what they're doing but
they're just tired or they don't want
the hassle
and then you can give them a guaranteed
rent and you can split it up and and
rent it on
as a super event and keep the monthly
cash flow like there's just so much
but what i will say is the pro the pie
is so big
and when there's a big pie you can slice
it up in different ways
and um there's enough money in the game
for everybody for the investor the
developer the landlord the manager
the sorcerer depends on which side of
the coin
you lie on and what your skills are so
louis
i wish you all the best and again hope
see you at the property investors crash
course
bertie evans can you please address your
thoughts on the average
age people buy their first house in the
uk which is 34.
i'm 15. i want to get into property as
soon as i can when i'm 18 is this
possible
yes bertie i bought my first house age
17 however it wasn't
a home that i lived in it was an
investment that i rented out i did it
using none of my own money
it was a creative strategy that i used
my thoughts about the average age being
34
are the i think it's woeful i think it's
a disgrace
i think that they're pushing back and
back and back the age of everything
they're pushing back the age of
adolescence
i mean but i speak to my granddad and it
was like
he was working at 13 14. now it's oh no
you're a teenager and now adolescent
ways have lessons in the
now there's so many 20 i'm 29. there's
people
i've got i've got two kids a third a
third kid on the way i'm married i've
been married now six years
um live in a nice big house i've got
lots and lots of people that work for me
i'm 29. people i know people that i went
to school with
that are living with their parents that
playing playstation
it's an embarrassment to be honest and
i'm not i'm not bragging about my wealth
it's more it's not even about wealth
about responsibility
if i say i'm a man so yeah i think it's
a joke
um however that's just my thoughts you
comment your thoughts below as well and
don't forget
ask your questions comment them below
aaron bennett
samuel can you turn a lease option
agreement into a hmo and if so what are
the regulations around it yes you can
uh the regulations around it are just
the same as the regulations when you're
buying a hmo so the licensing the
planning is all the same
uh if you're doing a lease option
agreement you just need to make sure
that there's not a mortgage on the
property that prohibits you from doing
it as a hmo
so that's the big thing to check ronald
des chain
can you explain more about section 24
tax section 24
tax is a tax that was put in for
landlords that own properties in their
personal name
that says that they cannot anymore um
claim their
mortgage payments their interest
payments back as tax
deductible which is a big problem so the
ways around it to buy through a limited
company or to buy a property which
the use is serviced accommodation so you
get commercial rates
um but yeah section 24 was a real pain
they announced it some years ago but
they phased it in until 2020
and you know a lot of people were
thinking they were going to reverse it
but they never did reverse it but what
they did was instead of reversing it
that they always have loopholes so the
loophole is to buy through a company
and what most people do is they whinge
about it oh man oh they just did this
change and they focus on the problem oh
look at this ball
whereas what rich people do is they find
the loophole
you know poor people by the way and i'm
not talking necessarily just about your
bank i'm talking about your mindset
poor minded people focus on the problem
whereas rich minded people focus on the
solution so there's always solutions
around these taxes and things
all right raz van gabriel can you get a
personal loan and use it to buy a house
within a limited company um if it's a
personal loan
that would usually mean that the purpose
of the loan is for personal reasons
buying a property through a limited
company renting out is not personal
reasons
it's an investment reason so
no you can't do that i mean i know a lot
of people that do it and just
it's kind of crazy isn't it that you if
you say to a bank
can you give me a 20 grand to get
married and they'll give you the 20
grand to get married
but then if they find out that you
actually didn't use it to get married
you actually
only had a 2 000 pound wedding after all
and you use the eighteen thousand to
invest
that they'd be like oh you can't do that
that's fraud it's like fraud
what having a cheap wedding and then
using the money to but
these are the rules i don't make them up
i just follow them so uh yeah no you
can't you can't do that
whenever you get a loan you always need
to make sure that the purpose of the
loan
you use it for that purpose if there's
no purpose then it's no problem
sergio where's the best place to get
investors for joint ventures sixty to 70
000 pounds apart from you on december
haha you're gonna see me december at the
crash course um
i mean listen i do give a lot of money
away like last year i gave
a million pound million pound on my own
money i gave away to
you know to to my uh associate students
whatever
they then invest it um i'm not really
looking to do that so much these days
because i got so many deals on my own
going on um
but the best place for it to for
investors i mean the crash course is a
good start
you're going to be around hundreds of
investors um you need to add value to
people i don't know who you are sergio
i've never heard of you before
so if i haven't heard of you probably
lots of people haven't heard of you you
need to get
get known how do you get known get
people's attention add value help people
put yourself on the map get such good
deals
put them out there that people can't
can't not invest in your deals
make yourself investable um i'm sure
you'll find some people at the crash
course
i'll see you there bro dan goodwin
how much should i set aside to furnish a
hmo i'm looking at around a three bed
currently i'm on a factory furnishing so
i don't screw myself over
depends on the hmo how big it is it's a
three bed this is a small three
three-bed hmo
two or three grand it also depends how
high-end you want to go
you know are you gonna get are you gonna
pay for flat packers
that's another factor you might forget
you know you get all the stuff from ikea
and then you're like damn now i need to
pack it up
but i don't really know how to do it
i'll pay somebody so you know generally
speaking for like a three
or four bed hmo you're talking a few
thousand pounds i would say
to get a decent good standard razvan
gabriel
are you only buying houses in city
centers
would a hmo work if it's let's say
10 to 15 minutes away from the center
no i'm not only buying houses and
centers however hmos only work
incentives hmos only work where there's
people around this buzzing the shops
there's jobs
occupations that's where hmos work 10 to
15 minutes
depends what the city is if it's 10 to
15 minutes away from london
you're going to be just fine 10 to 15
minutes away from birmingham you'll be
okay
10 to 15 minutes away from middlesbrough
no
you need to be like 10 minute walk
away so depends i would say you're best
off doing market research by speaking to
some hmm management companies in that
particular area and finding out
neddy how do you get a mortgage on your
first property investment if it's a hmo
it appears lenders want landlord
experience
yeah most lenders lenders do want some
landlord experience before they'll start
letting you buy
you know big hmos and stuff uh there are
some lenders that will let you
rent buy a property and rent it out as a
small multi-let like room by room
um but you are very restricted so uh
speak to a mortgage broker
get them to check all the different
lenders but maybe consider starting off
with your first investment as a single
letter
chris gravville graveless
yo samuel appreciate your videos and
also love how much you put your trolls
in their place
i try sometimes i ain't got time though
so you need to do that for me chris if
you see them
you just jump on them i'm subscribed and
i always smash the like button well in
that case chris you're awesome you
should come around my house for dinner
i got two questions for you another
youtuber said that investors
shouldn't do too many brr buy
refurbished finance rent
deals as you might find yourself too
highly leveraged
would you be able to explain what this
means and what are the dangers of being
too highly
leveraged yeah i would probably uh have
to nicely kindly disagree with the other
youtuber
uh i don't know what the context that
they said it was but
what what that person probably meant was
if you're doing
if you're doing thing is no i don't
agree with them at all because if you're
doing brr deals
the whole point is you're buying a
property and you're pushing the value up
and then you're and then you're getting
a new mortgage 75 percent learn to value
against the new value
so you you've got a 25 stake in that
property of your own money
even though you pulled all your money
out because of the way you structured it
so depends on what you consider highly
leveraged
i don't consider 75 loans of value and
particularly highly leveraged
what what the risk is is if you own lots
of houses
and the and the banks effectively own
i don't own but they've got 75 loan
against the value of the house that's
what 75
loan to value means and then the value
drops
by say 25 suddenly you've got no equity
in the house
which means that if you were to sell it
you'd make nothing on it
so that's what it would mean by no
equity or if it drops even further down
then you're in negative equity but i
don't think houses are going to drop
that low and even if they do i'm not too
worried because
uh i'm not worried about being a
negative equity i'm worried about
running out of cash flow so if the
property's dropped down and i'm getting
but i'm still getting my rent which of
course i will be my mortgage hasn't gone
higher
i'm chilled i'm good you can fix
interest rates for five ten years
so i would disagree i would very much
disagree
and you had a second question this would
be the last one now so let's see
when viewing houses are making offers
how do you work out how much the refurb
of a house might cost
good question as a newbie should i
always have a bill to come out on
viewings or is there a formula that you
use
to come up with a rough figure for
refurb costs so
chris there is a formula yes it's it's
not again i can't
i do run training promos you know where
i go through in degree
detail how to work out the costs and
stuff however
if you're not a builder just as a normal
person i consider myself as just a
normal person because
like yes i've worked on a building site
i used to be a plasterer i've been in
property for 12 years
i've got a pretty good idea how much
things cost but i miss
stuff and i'm not sure because i'm not a
building surveyor i miss stuff
i'm just i'm just an investor um so
the first thing is i would get good and
learn how much things generally cost
um however if you can't do that it's not
practical to bring a builder to every
viewing
no builder is just gonna want to come
out and be your wingman and
give you a ballpark figure of every
house that you look at
they're not going to want to do that so
my suggestion would be to ask the estate
agent what they think the rough quote
might be
you know how much do you reckon this is
going to cost and then they might be
like i reckon about 10 grand but i'm not
really sure
yeah well look i'll put my offer forward
but obviously subject to the survey i'll
have to get a builder out and surveyor
out
so i'll put my offer forward at x and
then they'll accept
then once you've had your offer accepted
then send a builder and a surveyor and
everything out
based on what they thought and you know
um
so that's generally generally what what
i would say but there's no black or
white right or wrong answer
also depending on the area depends on
the quotes as well london of course is
going to be much more expensive than if
you're up north
i i can do a whole refurb on the house
for like five to ten grand
if i go really far up north whereas
you'd probably struggle to do
in the house that i live in i mean jeez
that that wouldn't touch the kitchen
you know so so that's why i can't just
say i can't just say
this is how much a kitchen costs this is
because this it really really varies but
i hope that advice was helpful
and guys i'm here every day i'm here
every day
i'm answering your questions every week
on a sunday i do his q a and then
um on every wednesday i interview
somebody who's my success student
someone's gone through the training and
then i interview them every single week
and they share
their journey if you have become
financially free
from my training then why don't you
reach out go to whimsday.com
and put your story in or fill out the
form and we'll get you on the channel
how cool would that be
if you'd like to one day be sat here
with me
sharing your story on winners on a
wednesday but you aren't financially
free yet then i would suggest coming to
the property investors crash course it
all starts with the crash course
i'll leave in the description i'll leave
a link where you can come for free
isn't that amazing and don't forget to
watch more videos don't forget to
comment your questions below and i'll
answer next week
thanks for watching smash the like
button subscribe and i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
you